nous vous prions de nous excuser
d'interrompre internet quelques instants
afin de laisser la place à monsieur le
président de la république pour un
entretien au coin du feu
décidé à la dernière minute bonsoir
monsieur dame cher public spectateur
tous a lâché 1 les copains ça va bon là
on est là pourquoi du feu c'est le
rapport un entretien au coin du feu pour
avec monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
qui est président de delta qui est
présidente tarik nous sommes très bien
doté le quoi il est président c'est
marqué sur la présidente de la
république française
normalement c'est jacques essentielle
qui devait assurer l'entretien mais il
est un peu il est un peu patraque c'est
à dire qu'il a hélas il avalé un
échiquier
il a passé une radio mais moi je vais
très bien faire la faire pour
l'entretien avec président je pense que
deux le président devrait plus tarder
maintenant
bonsoir mon président bonsoir madame
bonjour mademoiselle bonsoir monsieur je
suis venu pour répondre aux questions
que vous êtes en droit de vous poser
concernant l'actualité gouvernement cac
blue chauffer les mimines sur le
remercie et j'aimerais d'ailleurs élu d
un certain nombre de malentendus dont un
qui consiste à prétendre que le
président connaît les questions à
l'avant bien c'est faux et ne connaît
que les réponses
ouais je vais vous monsieur le président
nous allons évidemment parler des
municipales à nous gagnons non sa nounou
j'ai demandiez tenant les visions n'en
parle pas alors vous êtes gens qui vous
abstenez vous parler d'autre chose il y
at il urgence plus cruciale la culture
c'est quand même demain ses marques et
c'est pas demain rible il ya plus
crucialement leurs voeux voilà on peut
peut-être parler du chômage c'est un
autre occupant c'est bien je suis
heureux que vous me parliez du chômage
ah ben on savait que nous connaissons
une période euphorique de chômage en
france puisqu'il ya environ plus de
chômeurs cette année que l'année
dernière mais nettement moins que
l'année prochaine
si tu fais que grosso modo
économiquement parlant la france arrive
nettement avant le brain lente
ouais bah c'est le principal face du
monde qu'on est en projet de l'anru ils
ont dix ans andy lau bon ben monsieur le
vice jusqu'à machin appelé mois valérie
l'enchère vallier tout ça je pense qu'on
pourrait maintenant aborder le problème
des municipales qui est quand même assez
n'ont eu qu'un jeune âge j'ai demandé
qu'on ne parle pas des municipales à la
télévision même pas demain parce que ces
deux maxis
écoutez il ya d'autres peut-être parler
du franc le franc on peut pas dire que
oui on s'assoit l'euphorie pour si vous
savez le franc est fort quoi qu'on dit
le franc est stable francs et tenace on
peut parler du franc suisse se vident à
blanc ouais bah c'est pas loin de son
snowshow à côté il y en a qui
connaissent le chemin
ah ben ça on peut pas parler d'eux dans
le plus de ça parce que lang maintenant
mon cher
lis tous les amis je peux t'appeler le
sable chaud du moc valérie valérie ci
est un problème de l'heureux
actuellement c'est celui des municipales
qui comme norme wi mais on ne peut pas
en parler
près du tout même nom alors si si un
problème pas de le re voilà on nous dit
de partout monsieur valéry qu
actuellement l'armée connaîtrait des
problèmes militaires notamment ceux
singulièrement il s'agirait il vaut
mieux qu'elles ne connaissent que des
problèmes d'ordre militaire
oui c'est fondamental oui et je vous
dirais que j'ai tout fait pour rehausser
le prestige de l'armée puisque lorsqu'il
ya eu la grève des éboueurs et
qui est-ce qui a ramassé les poubelles
si vous monsieur président non c'est
l'armée c'est l'armée oui voyez
l'appareil clanche que je lui témoin
d'ailleurs vous savez que la france est
prête à résister à toute agression
à condition que ça ne tombe pas le jour
de la grève des éboueurs
nous allons de plus en plus de femmes
dans l'armée nous avons madame des
proches notamment y entendre les cris de
ma femme parce que ça ne voudrait pas si
elle était là parce que mais oui les
femmes s'intéressent vous marrer que je
comprenais pas ce sont des pins direct
ce sont des femmes est patente
je les passe en revue de temps en temps
réel leur âge je me dis avec elle
la france est inviolable ah bon là on
glisse si on parlait des minimes si l'on
écouté et moi pour tout j'ai demandé que
l'on ne parle pas des municipales à la
télévision dans alors on pourra
peut-être aborder le plus haut mais mon
cher valérie que vous allez voir que
c'est pas de la tarte
le rapport à l'université l'université
connaît d'élucider m'écouter en ce qui
concerne l'univers séité je dois vous
dire que la rentrée scolaire s'est fort
bien passé puisque je ne mendie qu'il
est de plus en plus de crs de façon à
effectuer dans les meilleures conditions
possibles le ramassage scolaire
oui alors voilà comment ça s'est passé
après un examen de passage à tabac
les élèves ont été ramenés chez eux la
plupart du temps dans un état
satisfaisant pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique française
wils essentiel et fondamental
fondamental dans cette fin de semaine à
voir mais j'aurais aimé qu'on me
critiquer cette femme ou mais il me
donner votre sentiment à propos d'une
phrase que monsieur mitterrand a dit
l'autre jour dans son langage admirable
donne enfin dans son langage banal dans
dans son jargon dégueulasse il a dit il
parlait il a dit enfin c'était pas très
intéressant je suis surpris il est
monsieur mitterrand donc dit elle en
parlant de marché monsieur marchait
marché et moi nous sommes comme cul et
chemise est ce que vous pouvez délayé
m'expliquer cette phrase une cantine clé
avant d'aller au fond des choses
non on ne peut pas tout de suite parce
que moi je suis un goûter l'avant il
faudrait savoir lequel des deux faits la
liquette ah oui en plus tout mais toute
façon vous en foutez vous vous situez au
dessus des partis
vous l'avez déjà dit vous avez une
allemande alors quand c'est pas
tellement mon président pour peut-être
s'en aller
donc on ne parle pas de ne pas parler
d'eux c'est bien simple on aligne le
droit de parler d'eux
ni des élections l'unité l'école
municipale qui ont lieu demain à deux
mains mais qui touche aux urnes et
sodium peut pas passage français
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs quand
on n'a plus rien à dire on se retire
bonsoir